hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem binary search
we're given an array of integers nums
which are going to be sorted in
ascending order and we're also given a
target integer that we're going to look
for if the target exists in the array
then we can return the index of it if it
does not exist then we return one the
goal is to create an efficient algorithm
that can run in log n time so what
algorithm are we going to use well the
problem pretty much tells you binary
search so while this is self-explanatory
and a pretty basic algorithm i still
think it's really important because a
lot of problems kind of extend the idea
of binary search and then make it even
harder and this is actually a pretty
common interview question to be asked
some variation of binary search so this
is a very good problem to practice and
your goal should be able to implement
binary search very quickly basically as
if you were doing it in your sleep so
i'll try to explain this quickly but
also in a beginner-friendly way so the
input array is sorted the target value
could exist anywhere in this array or it
might not exist at all when we start we
are considering the entire input array
how are we going to do that well we're
going to have two pointers one pointer
is going to be at the leftmost index
which is initially index zero another
pointer is going to be at the rightmost
index these pointers mean that we are
considering the entire range now if we
could only look at one of these values
which one should we look at should we
look at the leftmost if we do that and
we see that it's not equal to the target
then we've only eliminated one
possibility and we still have to search
all of these if we look at the rightmost
similarly it's not the target so we've
only eliminated one possibility we still
have to look at the rest of them but if
we look at the midway point and
technically either of these could be the
midway point the way we calculate it
though is going to be literally taking
the left and right indexes and dividing
them by two which i think will lead us
to this position but approximately the
halfway point why should we look here
well we can compare it to the target
it's not equal to the target so what
does that tell us have we only
eliminated one possibility no because
remember the input array is sorted so if
this is not equal to the target we
should also ask is it smaller than the
target or is it larger than the target
in this case it's smaller than the
target so if this is smaller than the
target then everything to the left of it
is also going to be smaller than the
target so this was our midway point
we'll call it m and we found that it's
smaller than the target so we can
eliminate these three values from
consideration everything over here how
are we gonna you know represent that in
code well we're gonna take this left
pointer and then shift it to be m
plus one so now our left pointer is
gonna be over here this represents
possible range of solutions is going to
lie within you know these two pointers
so at this point we're just going to
repeat the algorithm repeat what i
pretty much just did now if we take
these two add them together divide by
two the middle is going to be over here
so then we're going to check is this
equal to the target that we're looking
for in this case yes it is so now we can
return the index because that's what we
were trying to do we can return m
whatever it happened to be i think it's
4 in this case so that is pretty much
the idea of binary search okay so now
the time complexity if you know binary
search you already know that it runs in
log in time but let's quickly understand
why so we're not considering this
example anymore but suppose we had 16
values in the input array every time we
go to the midway point we either find
the target but if we don't find the
target we know we're at least going to
eliminate half of the possibilities so
we would eliminate this down to a now
we're only looking at eight values we
still don't find the result we keep
dividing it by two make it two remaining
and then finally there would only be
one value remaining and either that's
going to be the target or it's not going
to be the target and then we're pretty
much done with the algorithm anyway so
the question is if we have a while loop
the while loop is going to run as many
times as we can divide the length of the
input array by two how many times can we
divide it by two well if you remember
from your math class that is a math
equation called log base two of n this
evaluates to how many times can we
divide n by 2. and you know suppose it
evaluates to be x that's equivalent to
saying that 2 to the power of x is going
to be equal to n okay but this is too
much math maybe you don't even care but
that's pretty much the idea that's why
our loop is going to run x times which
is going to be equal to log n so it's
not a big o of n algorithm it's a log
base 2 n algorithm which is much much
more efficient
okay so now let's code it up and like i
did in the drawing initially we're
considering the entire input array as
our search area so our left pointer is
going to be at zero our right pointer is
going to be at the last index which is
just the length of the array minus 1.
now we want to continue going until
there's no more possibilities left or we
have maybe found the result so the way
to do that is to basically say that
while our left pointer is less than or
equal to our right pointer because i
didn't show it in the drawing picture
but suppose we just had a very small
input array just to illustrate the
example our left and right pointers
would both point here our midpointer
would also point here but suppose our
target is actually equal to two okay
we'd say okay this is too small for our
target so we're gonna set our left
pointer to be equal to mid plus one so
that means our left pointer would be one
and our right pointer would be zero that
basically means our left pointer has
crossed our right pointer and that's how
you know that we have no more values
left to search we did not find the
result so that's why we're doing less
than or equal if they're both equal
though if they're both pointing at this
value that means we haven't looked at
this value yet so that's the idea so
each iteration of the loop we're just
going to find the midway point which we
can get by taking l plus r and dividing
by two if the value that this index is
at is greater than the target then we
want to look at all values to the left
of it so we're gonna take our right
pointer and set it to m minus one we
wanna look at all values to the left
we're basically shrinking our criteria
and in the other case else if that num
is smaller than our target then we're
gonna do the opposite we're gonna set
left equal to mid plus one just like in
the drawing explanation the last case is
if neither of those are true that must
mean that we found the target if it's
not greater and not smaller that means
it must be equal that means we can
return m which is the result but if we
went through every iteration of the loop
and we didn't find the result then
outside of it we are told that we should
return negative one to indicate we did
not find a result so that's the solution
let's run it to make sure that it works
and as you can see on the left yes it
does and it's very efficient there's one
more thing though that i want to mention
to you which probably won't come up in
your interview to be honest it's never
come up in mine but there's actually one
little bug here i mean technically the
bug doesn't exist in python because
python
integers are unbounded they can pretty
much be infinitely large but in most
languages like java and c plus plus you
might encounter an overflow because
suppose we had a very large input array
and then these two integers were very
close to the 32-bit integer max which is
something like
2 to the power of 31 suppose they were
both close to that then adding them
together would possibly overflow and
then we would get the wrong result in
this
value so possibly your interviewer might
ask you something about that and how
would you go about fixing that well
there's actually a way to do that we can
still calculate the midway point between
left and right without adding them
together because we can take the
distance between them we can get the
distance between them by taking right
minus left and then dividing that by two
right that will give us half of the
distance between them and we can take
that and add it to the left index
because if this is halfway of the
distance between them and then this is
the left index by adding these together
we are getting the midway point this is
just a way to do the exact same
calculation but this way it will never
overflow because right is always going
to be greater than or equal to left and
in this case we're not adding them
together we're subtracting them so this
will always be positive or it will be
zero so i'll run it and it does work
pretty much exactly the same as you can
see on the left but this is just
something i think a lot of people don't
talk about and actually i pretty much
never implement it this way people have
actually mentioned that in my comments
before which is kind of why i'm talking
about it today but i really hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it really supports the
channel a lot consider checking out my
patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching